[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about democracy for a minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ]
[Music]
good morning to you all
welcome welcome welcome to friday
we're here we didn't make it to the
hearing yesterday a lot of new evidence
comes up
a lot of new evidence that we haven't
seen yet uh comes to bear uh we we knew
some of this stuff you know again a lot
of this you know quote unquote evidence
is stuff that we have known about we
just haven't
seen
the crime yet um yesterday a couple of
things number one the judge
at the very end when he said he would
lay his body down out
in context
you know because everyone's calling oh
he's a liberal leftist he's woke or
whatever the [ __ ] i don't i don't know
and we're gonna play clip by jim jordan
today
jim i don't report sex crimes jordan
talking about
nothing he learned nothing new from the
evidence that was presented well i mean
i think there's a lot of things that
we've learned there's a lot of things we
assumed but there's a lot of things
we've learned jim jordan
we assumed that john eastman was trying
to help donald trump overthrow the
government
we assumed that donald trump was
grifting his supporters when when
journalists could not find this election
fund anywhere we assume that
we have evidence now but jim jordan's
saying the whole time oh my god i knew i
knew this was a grip the whole time of
course of course donald trump stole 250
million dollars away from his supporters
to act like he was putting it in a fund
that does not exist of course he did
that jim jordan
is not surprised by this
we learned yesterday that that john
eastman
was trying to even after january 6
and during january 6
when jacobs greg jacobs the former
counsel to the vice president mike pence
who they wanted to hang and kill
that's the other evidence we found out
that yes the proud boys do want to kill
mike pence wanted to kill him on january
6 and we've seen the videos of the
people being stoked to kill mike pence
we remember
the very ominous chant hang mike pence
everyone remembers that and bring out
mike pence
why'd you want to bring him out was
there a gallows there or something hmm
seems kind of funny
but the proud boys and there's
there's evidence
uh an informant apparently has said yes
they would have killed mike pence if
they would have got their hands on him
the other thing that we that we saw
in the hearing
was mike pence standing in the parking
garage
trying to hold the government together
with a cell phone and a piece of paper
and a pen
trying to keep it together there
he was desperate and really honestly
this is this is partly of mike pence's
doing here uh everyone wants to hail
mike pence as if he saved democracy i
think that judge that spoke yesterday in
dan quayle the guy who can't spell
potato probably did more to save our
democracy than mike pence i believe mike
pence was looking for a way to please
his orange mussolini jesus
and there just wasn't a legitimate way
to please him if there would have been
we would have been [ __ ]
if there would have been one one un
wackadoo
i mean there's plenty of wackadoos
around like john eastman
sydney powell rudy giuliani
mike flynn
his children there was plenty of
wackadoos standing around going oh my
god yeah you can do this
you can you can decide who the president
is mike pence i mean even john eastman
didn't really believe this [ __ ]
he didn't even really believe it when
the supr when
when greg jacob jacobs questioned him on
the supreme court overturning it he said
yeah we'll probably lose
and he said we'll lose like two to se it
would lose two to seven
but then he admitted to greg jacobs that
they would lose 9-0 but he even admitted
that al gore didn't have this power
neither does kamala harris well if those
vice presidents don't have this power
john eastman
neither does neither does the one who
stands next to your orange mussolini
jesus
but jim jordan he did he knew all this
already jim jordan knew all this
he knew all this stuff he knew about the
eastman emails
to greg jacobs when greg jacobs said
look what you did you dumb [ __ ]
in so many words
you you caused this [ __ ]
and john eastman pushed back and said no
you did this because you wouldn't go
with our plan to overthrow the
constitution of the united states they
were desperate folks
they were desperate and this wasn't just
one one singular plan they had a lot of
contingencies what do you think that qrf
that the oath keepers were stashing
across the river was
you think somehow the proud boys cued in
on mike pence without donald trump
conspiring with him and i don't mean
like he sat down and had a meeting and
they drank beers together
that was the whole point of the whole
scheme
is to froth up violence and they're
still doing it
they're still doing it today
jim jordan blaming
in a tweet blaming gas prices on the
january 6th select committee you know
and for all intents and purposes
two things that have nothing to do with
each other
just like joe blaming joe biden for
[ __ ] gas prices
you people really are [ __ ] boneheaded
out there if you think anyone besides
the oil company has a goddamn button
that changes gas prices and really
american people until you [ __ ] pluck
your head out of your ass and start
blaming the right [ __ ] for high
gas prices they're gonna keep going up
you think they're gonna stop if you're
blaming someone but them
think about this if you were in control
of gas prices if you had the button to
control gas prices and it was fill in
your pr pockets for record profits
and everyone's complaining about the
price of your product your gas
but they're blaming anyone but you
would you [ __ ] change the price of
fuel hell no you turn that [ __ ] up
jim jordan voted against
against he voted against holding oil
companies accountable
for gouging
record profits
triple the profits
jim jordan's going to bring blame joe
biden the january 6 select committee
jesus [ __ ] christ
and folks this idea that somehow we won
a recession is another [ __ ]
boneheaded scheme
but it's always it's always distraction
with these [ __ ] like jim jordan
and we're going to watch this interview
today because i think the interview when
jim jordan is talking into a microphone
to one of these trader tv networks
because i think it's one it's either
newsmax or oan or one of these trader tv
networks
they're all one and the same anymore
it's all the same nonsense all the same
[ __ ] drivel just [ __ ] lies
that they pump into the americans brains
hell the mainstream media is on that now
oh joe biden can't run in 2024 and all
this [ __ ] what the [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out
of here man we got more we got better
[ __ ] to do than worry about who the
[ __ ] gonna run in 2024 you dumb
[ __ ]
we got an election this year
why is the media talking about 2024 why
why
you are a bunch of dumb sons of [ __ ]
they love the freedom of press until
they won't have it no more
so maybe maybe free press i'm talking to
you
maybe you should do your [ __ ] job
and talk about the [ __ ] that matters
right [ __ ] now the election the next
one
not 2024 who gives a rat's ass
i i don't give a rat's ass at this point
hell we might not have a 2024 election
if we don't [ __ ] engage in this one
that's how democracy works it's the next
one
why the [ __ ] are they talking about 2024
joe biden's gonna be the president until
then anyways
so what do you give a [ __ ]
but jim jordan just didn't learn
anything
from the last three hearings he learned
not a goddamn thing he knew trump was
stealing money from his supporters he
knew bill barr thought it was all
[ __ ] he knew john eastman was in a
conspiracy to try to overthrow the
government with donald trump he knew he
knew mike pence was looking for a way to
make sure donald trump could remain king
but couldn't find one
he knew all this
he knew the proud boys would have hanged
mike pence he knew all this
we knew all of that
nothing new nothing new to see here
it feels like to me that
maybe jim jordan had the inside
information on this
maybe that's why he wanted to be on the
select committee in the beginning and
nancy pelosi dunked his [ __ ]
ass in the trash
nope not on this committee [ __ ]
very interesting that he would say that
real americans don't care about the
january 6 select committee
very interesting that he thinks that gas
prices are the only thing that americans
can can concentrate on this is another
reason why i think jim jordan is a
[ __ ] piece of trash himself
they really do believe you're dumb
they really do they think you're dumb
and just like that judge said if you
people don't wake up and realize they're
using you we will lose our democracy
they want a fascist state
this is not some kind of [ __ ] [ __ ]
lib judge that we're talking about here
this guy is more quote unquote
conservative than mike pence
he's probably not
allowed in a room with a woman alone
either
i'm just saying
january 6 select committee i appreciate
you guys joining us yesterday for the
broadcast over on midas touch youtube
channel it was fantastic um we're
gaining a lot of viewers over here on
our channel don't forget to subscribe
here at the tony michael's podcast on
youtube hit that subscribe button down
below
like subscribe do whatever you're
supposed to do you know makes it makes
me a good youtuber
but go over to midas touch channel
hopefully we'll have the next hearing uh
posted soon over there so you guys can
set your reminder for the link so be
looking for that i'm sure we'll get that
sometime today or tomorrow that way you
guys can set your reminder for the very
next hearing
next week there's two next week now
they're going to be the same time the
one yesterday
1pm eastern that's when they'll gavel
down the hearing but here's the thing if
you go over to midas touch youtube
channel
we will start our coverage at noon an
hour before with our panel and
commentary just like we did yesterday
and the two hearings prior
and then we do we will do commentary
during the break of the hearing and we
will do commentary following the hearing
with a panel as well now we've had some
great panels with us uh names like
michael cohen rachel bittikoffer david
bender my co-host gabe sanchez the
mizellas brothers michael popock
karen agnipolo from legal af as well
now we we've also had jessica denson on
yesterday who is the trump nda killer
she's the one who actually won the case
to kill trump's nba against her
go check that out and we should have
more and more and more great guests to
have on and talk to you and you guys
know the midas mighty favorite is texas
paul
uh boy has he given us some commentary
texas paul type commentary
so go go check that out go um go follow
over on midas touch youtube channel if
you're not already but be looking for
that link for the next hearing so you
can set a reminder
you don't want to miss the coverage that
we have on the midas media network over
there i appreciate you guys coming and
watching us host
me and gabe have enjoyed producing
the hearings for the mind as mighty and
for the world we've had record-breaking
views um on that so very exciting stuff
when it comes to i'm having you guys
engage in the democracy because that's
what it's about even though this stuff
boy some of it this evidence is pretty
depressing
it's some of it is like wow this is woo
holy holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
but it it feels good that you guys are
engaging in your democracy that you're
paying attention that's what you should
be doing
that's how this works that's how
democracy advances forward because
democracy is hard it's really [ __ ]
difficult democracy
it's not easy
because we don't all agree i'm sure most
of my audience that listens to me agrees
with me on most things
but probably not all the things that i
believe are all the things that i say
and that's not necessarily how it should
be we shouldn't have to agree on every
single little detail
but we can all agree that we should at
least participate engage and save our
democracy
regardless if you're a moderate and
independent of if you consider yourself
a democrat or a liberal or a socialist
or democratic socialist hell even a
conservative or republican
i would say that being pro-democracy is
something we all can agree on and if you
can't agree on that
if you can't agree on that then
that's what we're trying to fight back
from
just like the judge yesterday because i
would imagine that there's not one
goddamn thing that i would agree with
with greg jacobs or that judge hardly
not a [ __ ] thing
they would probably think i'm some kind
of crazy
obscene clown
which in all reality come on folks
but there's not one thing that i would
probably agree with these folks on
besides
the advancement of the idea
that a small liberal democracy
and our system of government where we
the people because of the 14th amendment
our control are in control
of our country and our future
we i think we believe that that is the
best course of action
i think that's what delivers equality in
equity to everyone now it's again it's
not perfect and we're not there and we
won't be the best we can be
maybe for decades and decades to come
but without democracy you look at the
model that they're trying to that
they're trying to create in florida with
that [ __ ] let's go brandon nazi ron
desantis
think about this for a second that's the
blueprint for their fascist state do you
want the do you want
the united states of america
to be run and and dictated like florida
is right now i can't even [ __ ]
imagine that anyone would vote for that
pile of [ __ ] down in florida
think about this the people that have
always been in the republican party big
government big government big government
telling me what to do i hate big
government you can't make me wear a mask
you are freedom of speech
jesus christ even elon musk of course
he's a [ __ ] joke
supports ron desantis
what
elon musk who bitched and complained
[ __ ] whine and complain during the
pandemic that the state of california
made him protect his employees from from
a disease inside his [ __ ] inside his
[ __ ] buildings
likes ron desantis who wants to shut
down disney because
mickey mouse is woke
elon you are such a dumb [ __ ]
you are a dumb [ __ ] and anyone
who believes anything that comes out of
that little cock's mouth
elon musk is a dumb [ __ ] too
you are a dumb [ __ ]
it is ridiculous
elon musk complaining about the
government telling him what to do
and then he he wants to support ron
desantis who wants to tell private
companies what they can and can't do
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
he's not who you think he is you dummies
he's lying to you he's a fraud he's an
idiot
he didn't invent electric cars [ __ ] he
didn't invent anything he bought all
that
he bought the ability to look like he
invented [ __ ]
and it sucks to suck elon and you suck
but that's their motto in florida that's
their model for the fascist state
just go look at what they're trying to
do they're trying to ban math they're
trying to ban books
you can't say the word gay in school you
can't talk about if you got if you got
gay parents you can't talk about it
because oh boy that's grooming
all the while they're focused on
children's genitalia and what bathrooms
they're going into
this is really [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] folks
now they want to marry children in
tennessee
they want to they want to make it to
where a woman can't cross can't cross a
state border to have a medical procedure
in missouri a felony
they're bounty hunting women in texas
over medical procedures
we're probably going to see
the roe v wade decision come down soon
um which is
again
going to change the whole dynamic of
this race that's why i don't understand
why the media is so focused on the next
one let's do this one first dummies
they really want a fascist state folks
they really want one and florida is
their blueprint
and ron desantis
ron desantis would love to be the next
donald trump and that's what he's
gearing up to do
but these january 6th select hearings
are designed to get the american people
the facts
so that way they can make reasonable
decisions here
reasonable decisions and i was talking
to someone the other day and i think i
said this on air with gabe
they had no idea no idea the evidence
that the defense the election defense
fund did not exist
and that they grifted 250 million
dollars in the name of a fund that
didn't exist
no idea no clue didn't know that i was
like whoa that was like the biggest news
that came out of that day
where the [ __ ] was your head when this
was going on when the news was being
announced but folks that's the rub here
is that most americans aren't paying
attention to these things and really
honestly most americans even americans
who voted for trump are like yeah he's
crooked he's a [ __ ] crook he's a
criminal
they realize that so why why pay
attention to anything that's said about
him because
and it's not surprising
but this is very important that you
engage
it's very important that's why i'm super
excited that so many people are watching
the hearings that we're producing
watching looking at the evidence seeing
it
seeing them talk but it's more important
for you to be talking about the evidence
that's there
that's the most important thing
engage with people
show them the clips show them the clips
that you're seeing on social media send
it to in a dm post it on social media
but when you're in front of them pull
that [ __ ] up on your phone and show them
look here we don't have newspapers
anymore who when's the last time you
seen a newspaper
your newspaper is right in your hand
it's right there
and have you ever been on social media
on the other side of social media here's
what i mean social media has a lot of
different corners in it right
you go to someone's page holy [ __ ] it
may it may look like a whole different
universe on twitter
than what your universe looks like
those people are not seeing what you're
seeing
so show them show your uncle earl and
your aunt edna those videos those clips
show them what happened
show them what happened boy it's a great
friday i'm excited for the weekend it's
father's day weekend i think i'm gonna
fire up the grill what are you guys
doing for father's day weekend are you
guys doing anything special
are you uh treating your favorite father
figure
are you guys going out to dinner or are
you are you having i i don't know are
you having a barbecue or you're having a
party
making a cake uh remembering the father
in your life maybe
um let's
let's remember all the great fathers
this father's day weekend
but let's have some fun and while you're
having fun let's make sure that you're
that you are
talking to those fathers talking to
those men because sometimes it's the men
that are
a problem
who
also tomorrow
someone's bringing up here in the chat i
believe uh let's see
there's so many people in the chat i
appreciate all the new listeners we have
here on the tony michaels podcast thanks
for joining us and coming back and
listening to us every single weekday
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
twitch and simulcasting
from the minus touch facebook page megan
says and juneteenth it is juneteenth
tomorrow
make sure you recognize that you know
we're going to talk about that today
because i want to ask gabe sanchez our
co-host and executive producer what his
opinion on is on juneteenth and and if
he knew about juneteenth i didn't
to be quite honest with you i didn't
know about juneteenth i didn't know
about it i had no clue
so i'm glad that i know now but i i
think i think the uh
the commer commercialization of
juneteenth
is kind of a little gross you know when
you're you're trying to sell bread and
and uh
i don't know
different things with juneteenth on it
it's a little
it's a little weird but uh you know and
i hope uh
i hope we uh get through that so and
juneteenth uh celebrated this this
sunday because today is the 17th so
juneteenth is this sunday father's day
so they fall on the same day this year
so be celebrating the exact same thing
all right exactly we'll be celebrating
two things on the exact same day is what
we will be
um so yes find find your your your
celebration this weekend find your joy
find your happiness
because
in light of what we're seeing with the
january 6th select committee and some of
this evidence and what republicans are
trying to do to our country don't let
them take it away from you
and what i mean by that is don't let
them take away your joy and your
patriotism um everyone everyone thinks
that oh my gosh you can't you can't you
can't be a patriot you can't you know
ashamed of the american flag because
they stole it away from us don't let
them steal it away
celebrate
celebrate these holidays
in a way that you remember what actually
happened because juneteenth is not
a
it's a great it's a great holiday
to celebrate i think of what happened of
the people that were liberated with the
truth
so
let's uh
let's celebrate father's day and
juneteenth appropriately and be patriots
and be patriots um
let's um let's do this let's go to a
break and when we come back hopefully
gabe sanchez will be joining us soon
and then we will go surf the tweety
tweets and the training trends because i
really want to show you this clip from
jim jordan and break it down with uh
with gay beer um this this clip of jim
jordan oh my god now we'll see
on a trader tv news network so stick
around don't go anywhere
we'll be right back right after these
messages
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your pardon blanket
today for just
99.99 actual parting's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
anybody else need a pardon blanket
the whole [ __ ] line of people lined
up to get a pardon blanket
john eastman maybe jim jordan
matt gatz parker taylor green lauren
scott terry paul
i'm sure there was a lot of people like
oh you're handing out pardons for
treason yeah sure i'll take one
absolutely i'll take a pardon for
seditious conspiracy for trying to
overthrow the government of the united
states you goddamn right i need a pardon
gonna need one of those
oh [ __ ] are you kidding me
gabe sanchez made that video
a long time ago that's not new that's
not new that video is old
when we found out that that
originally dropped in a rolling stone i
think is originally where that story
dropped that they were
members of congress were trying
to campaign for pardons now the word was
in that article that they were not just
campaigning for themselves but they were
also campaigning for other members of
the seditious coup
the cheeto dust kangaroo coup as it were
for oath keepers and cowboys for trump
which uh speaking of that i believe the
cowboys for trump guy is supposed to be
uh
sentenced today or something i think i
don't know that's scat mc mcfarlane
let's let's go to the uh
to the to the uh well
here we'll go to the timeline here in a
second
but these uh pardons are man that is a
real thing here's what i think after
listening to some of this evidence more
and more
because you got to kind of get into the
mind of donald trump about some of this
january 6 stuff right because
if
if john eastman was looking for a pardon
and he didn't get one and maybe he does
have one i don't know maybe he's got a
pocket pardon because he's not indicted
yet
maybe roger stone has one maybe maybe
rudy giuliani maybe mike flynn maybe
sydney powell i don't know there's lynne
wood
all these people all these characters
seem to come up
that could possibly have pardons
none of those people are indicted
makes me wonder that maybe if the doj
suspects
that there's possibly pocket pardons
that these people are carrying around
we've heard that word start to circulate
pocket pardon right
meaning that you would uh
meaning that you would
have a pardon in your pocket for when
you need it
you know
it would be like donald trump going oh
we all committed crimes so we better
pardon ourselves and just
keep it in the old pocket in case we
need it
because i guess that's a thing i don't
know if it's ever been challenged before
in a court
and that's
that's where
where it'll be challenged rather a
pocket pardon exist even if they have
them i don't know
gary burns here on youtube says like
pocket pool
i don't i don't know i don't know if
it's like that but
it possibly could be i guess so
maybe
i don't know
here's the thing
if these pocket if these pocket pardons
do exist
maybe that's why some of these people
aren't indicted yet and here's what i
mean by that now i'm just i'm just
surmising here but this evidence is
starting to show that these people knew
they were committing crimes
they knew it and other people knew it
too
and the white house counsel was telling
john eastman you better go get you a
[ __ ] criminal lawyer buddy and that
was on the day after january 6. so there
were still a couple weeks for john
eastman to go to donald trump to get his
little pardon that he needed
and apparently he campaigned for one so
maybe there was a pardon line and they
all got one
now why is that significant
it could be significant as the reason
why doj hasn't charged some of these
people yet and the reason why is because
they're trying to figure out what
charges to charge them on
because i don't think even doj knows how
a pocket pardon would would work
in a court
i don't know that we have any kind of
legal
history of what a pocket pardon could
and couldn't do
when you're pardoning yourself
from crimes that you know you've
committed but they don't know you've
committed yet
they haven't figured it out yet
i don't know i don't i have no idea some
people say that it's a legitimate pardon
but think about it maybe that's why
maybe that's why the doj is working
every single angle every single piece of
evidence because maybe they pardon
themselves from a certain amount of
things but forgot one or two things
forgot one or two statues that they
could be charged on i don't know
i don't know but this pardoned stuff
seems to be
at the forefront of some of this
evidence
i mean why would john eastman if he
really did truly believe what his his
legal theory
was valid would need a pardon for
why what would he need one for why would
he even imagine he would need one
i mean most people in this country
don't have any fear of kamala harris
handing over the election to herself
regardless of what the outcome is right
i mean like there's i i have
i have i am very
very confident
that kamala harris the vice president
united states currently
will will hand over a peaceful transfer
of power whether that's to the current
administration another administration
that's a democrat maybe possibly i don't
know joe biden could be challenged
or a republican i'm very confident that
she will do that that there won't be
this grand scheme to steal away the
democracy
and what the people want
now the republicans are going to work
really hard to steal
the certification that's what they're
working on right now that's the coup
that is ongoing right now as we speak
they're trying to make sure they install
maga trumpledites in these secretary of
state roles to be to be
the state official over elections and
then they want to change to how they can
do the certification so they can steal
away your vote
no matter how you vote they want to
steal it away from you
because their fascist ways are at risk
here because democracy is their enemy
but i am very confident very confident i
have no there's
and even john eastman admitted that al
gore had no right and neither will
kamala harris
well what the [ __ ] how much sense does
that make and really honestly i did a
video about this
right after the election when they were
floating this [ __ ] around that that mike
pence had the ability to crown a king
it's all nonsense
if that was the case why wouldn't joe
biden at the time think about it joe
biden was the vice president who
presided over the certification of
donald trump's win in 2016.
think about it
why wouldn't he just through it to
hillary
really is some dumbass [ __ ] just
bone-headed type stuff
but it doesn't matter because they were
desperate so desperate in fact that if
mike pence didn't do what they said they
were going to hurt him
he was hiding in a [ __ ] bunker and
again i don't want to make mike pence
into a hero because he's not here
because he perpetuated this by running
around acting like this was a viable
thing up until the very morning when
they released a statement saying he
wasn't going to do what they wanted him
to do he should unequivocally from the
very beginning said no the president
united states is trying to steal the
election he's trying to convince me to
steal the election he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
box and i'm not gonna do it
i'm on the side of democracy i don't
care if we lost or we won i'm on the
side of democracy but mike pence didn't
do that
he was looking for any way he could to
try to see if this was a valid way to
keep in power
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
that's why mike pence didn't didn't
[ __ ] testify
it's one thing that yesterday to try to
make mike pence as some kind of [ __ ]
hero now i will say the stark images
mike pence in a parking garage on a
loading dock
on a cell phone with a piece of paper
trying to hold our democracy together
because at that point
mike pence and his legal staff and his
staff in general had decided that we
can't do this it's criminal it's
unconstitutional to do this
he knew he'd be at legal risk that's why
mike pence didn't want to do it because
he wasn't even sure if it was going to
work the way that they wanted it to work
so at the very last moment yes mike
pence was holding the government
together
but not because he didn't try to see if
there was a way
that they could that they could take
down
the united states of america and the
vote that happened the election that
happened the free and fair election not
because he didn't try he definitely
tried i mean jesus christ he pressed the
guy who couldn't spell potato dan quail
several times
you sure dan are you sure are you you're
really sure like a hundred percent
you're sure sure like sure and churning
sure
of of course he wanted donald trump to
still be the king
he just was scared that he would be
locked up for it and i believe that mike
pence avoided criminal liability by
doing what he did
yesterday
seeing greg jacobs
and the judge mike lutwig let tig or and
i don't know the guy who talked very
slowly
the the hearing was very long because
one of the witnesses was very uh slow
talking i think he was very nervous to
be there
i think he was very nervous to be there
i think his i think i think honestly
both
the witnesses yesterday
vice president's uh formal counsel and
his informal counsel because that's who
was sitting there
i i believe that those two people's
lives are at risk here
they're probably getting death threats
their family and everything else because
they're really tearing apart
this narrative that donald trump won
they're ripping it to shreds is what
they're doing
now these two were forced to come and i
i don't think the judge actually wanted
to sit before the committee and speak
with his own words with his own face on
tv
but he did it he appeared he did his
duty and at the very end he said that he
would lay down his body on the road if
he had to
to stop the coup from happening
so we saw that yesterday in the video
and next week i believe the very first
hearing is going to be we're going to
see what the coup was a doj because this
is just a one-prong coup
they were trying to coup from all
different directions they were trying
the court system the supreme court they
were trying to state legislators they
were trying to get their own electors
fraudulently they were trying to get
audits they were pressuring secretary's
estate to overturn elections
anything donald trump could do to win
because he was desperate and the reason
why he was desperate folks is because
the pieces of evidence that keep coming
out is that donald trump his team and
everyone around him knew that he had
[ __ ] lost
the big lie is exactly that it's a big
[ __ ] lion they know it
and they continue to perpetuate this
stuff on their supporters and grift off
them
now we want to laugh at them and call
them dumb and stupid
but they're perpetuating a crime as we
speak
maybe in some jurisdictions i don't know
fraud is fraud
so we'll see let's get to the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends you know
that we surf the tweety tweets and
trendy trends every single weekday
and round up all the [ __ ] list here on
the tony michaels podcast we're going to
go to the second hour you guys know on
friday we do the bonehead too today's
friday bonehead of the week you guys
vote we break it down and you voted for
bonehead of the week this week you can
go to our our twitter page at
tonymichaelspot you can vote there or if
you subscribe on the youtube channel you
can also vote on youtube now for
bonehead of the week
don't miss it it's gonna be in the
second hour today so stick around for
both end of the week we're gonna surf
the tweety tweets and trendy trends
right now let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to d tony
michael's podcast we have reached the
part of the show where we round up all
the tweety tweets in the trendy trends
the [ __ ] list roundup
let's make this a little bigger so you
can see the screen here um again there's
there's a bunch of news this morning
that i want to get to um one a piece of
the news is
that's the jim jordan thing i want to
get to that but uh
uh scott mcfarlane has this uh he's
reporting sentencing today in the
january six case
uh otero county new mexico county
commissioner coy griffin this guy i
believe this guy is the uh the leader of
cowboys for trump i think
that's what the [ __ ] it's called
i think i don't know
i i don't know
it's one of these one of these trump
humping groups
um apparently he's not really even happy
with trump because he didn't pardon him
i i guess
i mean i've i've seen some videos of him
talking about how he's not really happy
with trump he thinks trump's a [ __ ] you
know trump called uh
mike pence a [ __ ] everyone's scared of
that word
why why is everyone scared of the word
they were saying the word [ __ ] yesterday
and they wouldn't say the word [ __ ] did
you notice that did you notice they were
terrified of the word that
sometimes is to identify women's
genitalia they're terrified of that word
why were they
i don't know i mean i it isn't
surprising to me that donald trump
called someone a [ __ ] he is a he is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] so yeah the projection's
real with that guy
and i mean he was trying to shame mike
pence into it calling him wimp or
whatever you know this or that
i'm just saying
uh
this guy here though and this
uh he's a again he's a county
commissioner this guy holds power in new
mexico this guy right here holds power
and today he's going to be sentenced in
the january 6 case
says per new mexico secretary of state
griffin is being referred for possible
criminal investigation in new mexico
for refusing to certify local election
results so not only is this guy
participating in january 6.
he was an ongoing participation in the
coup the cheeto dust kangaroo coup
in that one prong where they're trying
to stop from certifying election results
remember this wasn't just one plan like
one oh there's one thrust
we'll just have mike pence crown donald
trump king no that what that was just
part of it that was part of it that's
what we're learning through these
january 6th select hearings these public
hearings oh my god they were all over
the map
it ain't no wonder this guy couldn't do
a roll out of the vaccine you guys
remember that the end of 2020 after he
had lost the vaccine started to roll out
it was horrible it was botched they
[ __ ] it up because he didn't he
couldn't concentrate on anything but
trying to overturn the election
and now we know why he was busy i mean
he was busy
working hard to make sure he was the
president of the united states come
january 20th illegally
i mean he was committing crime after
crime after crime after crime to try to
make sure this happened
calling secretaries of state making sure
that local officials were refusing to
certify election results
yeah
but it looks like um this guy who's
gonna be sentenced in a federal court
today
will is being um criminally investigated
in new mexico so that is the news from
scott mcfarlane these stories are going
to continue folks we also had news
yesterday
that the proud boys hearing got pushed
back to december okay and that's super
important um now
no one can make the claim that that's
all political for this election
no one can make that claim now doj has
pressed that that that trial to december
which means that trial will happen after
this election now some may say that's a
bad thing right we want justice before
the election we want to know and that
may be the case
but now think about it they can't make
they can't make the claim that the oath
keepers and the proud boy trial is
somehow political and tied to this
election
come on that you can't make that claim
now
that trial is pushed way back past the
election
so don't let anyone make that claim now
we can actually scrutinize the evidence
that january 6 select committee puts out
that's the whole point of us public
knowing what happened that day on
january 6 and what led up to it and even
after it
so yeah
yeah we can have the evidence in our
hands and say it's not political because
these people aren't going to go on trial
until after
the the midterms this isn't about the
election
so
but these people tried to overturn the
election and i think that's the point
i think that's the point and maybe if we
can get america to pluck its head out of
its ass and realize and hey maybe we
shouldn't be electing people who are
seditious and at this point anyone who
supports trump or trump allies
should really think about are they
traitors or not
this guy obviously
obviously
is a seditionist
if he's
i mean
if he's been convicted with january 6
and he's under possible criminal
investigation for refusing to certify
election results that's what they're
doing folks that's what they're going to
continue to do
um some good news
in the news jimmy carter is trending for
a good thing a good thing i seen jimmy
carter saying oh no
oh no uh michael brown here has a
picture of jimmy carter on a plane
um the tweet says jimmy carter got on
our plane and was seated in first class
got up before the plane left
and shook every single hand on the plane
and thanked everybody the plane erupted
in applause and tears it was awesome
everyone loves jimmy carter everyone
loves jimmy carter
he's like your grandpa but the guy the
guy
has done so much good for our country
not not just when he was a politician
and not just when he was a peanut farmer
but the guy has used his influence has
used
his his pro-democracy mind to help
people in this country habitat for
humanity has provided housing for
hundreds and thousands
of americans and giving people hope
giving people a way of life
which we should do more of
of that in this country that's that's
what that's what freedom and liberty
looks like
right there in that picture with jimmy
carter
um
and i want to tell you something
when i first seen this picture
i got excited
and the reason why i got excited is
because
we'll see barack obama in these types of
pictures
we'll see joe biden in these types of
pictures
you will never
you will never
in a million years
a gazillion years ever see donald trump
get on a commercial plane in first class
and you definitely
well i mean unless he's handcuffed by
the feds and they're transporting him
somewhere
but she will never
you will never see donald trump get up
and shake everyone's hand and thank them
no [ __ ] way not even not gonna happen
in a million years
and that's the difference folks
that's the difference between decency
that's the difference see difference
between someone who sees another
person's humanity
and fascists who don't
they decouple humanity
from all things
and that's the
difference so thank you jimmy carter
thank you jimmy carter
for being a decent human being
and using your influence
and your name
to advance great american causes for
great americans thank you so much
um adam parkaminko posted this uh video
of
of mike lindell i always love goofing on
mike linda this is an old video
i've watched this video a long time ago
and i don't know if adam knew that or
not i mean i mean it's really it
maybe it isn't this could be the exact
same scenario
um that happened over and over
and i'm just thinking that it was that
video but i think this is an old video
i think
this is an old video
but this is mike lindell here at the
beginning here
let me go back and read adam's tweet
first oh this is hilarious
adam says just mike lindell sitting in
his undies in public nothing to see here
now you think what wait a second adam
are you telling me are you telling me
that mike lindell is in it because he
looks like he's in a suit coat here
right
he looks like he's in a suit coat and
he's got his cell phone here he's kind
of got a tripod looks like he's looks
like he's yelling conspiracy theories
into the camera there
but he claims he's in his undies i've
seen this he is in his undies what's
what's he's sitting out i don't know
this looks like a courtyard at a motel
and this looks like a motel because you
got the door here
with the little lock on it and you got
the air conditioners here underneath the
windows it seems like this is some kind
of resort hotel and this is like an
atrium where there's
some tables and stuff and he's set up
outside for better lighting maybe i i
don't know that way when he's yelling
conspiracy theories into the into the
trader tv network that whatever trader
tv network he's on
maybe maybe they can see him
doing that you know you gotta have good
lighting you gotta have good [ __ ]
lighting when you're committing treason
and sedition jesus christ
but this is an old video but watch he is
in his undies watch
so we don't have that now brandon
keep fighting man keep fighting don't
don't let the lip tarps there you go uh
let me pull the banner down so you can
see it of course this guy is trolling
him and this guy knows he's live on tv
but look there
look at michael lindell he is in his
undies
those are pad pattern printed boxer
shorts but he's got his shooting tie on
you know i mean
hell i'm i might be sitting in my
underwear right now you just don't know
it you don't know how do you know you
can't see
but the thing is i'm i'm sitting in my
studio this guy's sitting out in a hotel
atrium where everyone's walking by and
going what the [ __ ] is this crazy guy
doing jesus christ this guy needs to you
think
you would think for a guy who
manufactures pillows for a living would
take a [ __ ] nap every once in a while
this guy needs a [ __ ] nap
jesus christ he's off his rocker
take a nap mike but let's let's watch
this is great trolling by the way again
this is an older video but it never
hurts to refresh everyone's memory
how nutty
mike lindell is and the president of the
united states was listening to this guy
when they were trying to overthrow the
government think about that that's the
context of this
donald trump the president united states
at the time where they were trying to
commit a cheeto dust kangaroo coup was
listening to this guy holy [ __ ]
call your names don't let them call you
an ethnically dubious pillow pusher
don't let them call you a a marginally
uh brave i love how he tries to power
through it by the way mike lindell is
trying to power through here really
trying to power through and make sure
that he gets his point across here on
live tv of course this guy is not
is not having it whatsoever none addled
uh corrupt
goofball
well you're doing great don't let them
call your names what i'm saying what i'm
saying is be strong don't let them push
you around or call you names like a
really clueless crazy old man who
believes everything he reads on the
internet don't let them call you names
stay strong you're doing great love you
man
[Laughter]
i don't know who the guy is that took
this video but oh my god is he a patriot
that's a real true patriot right there
baby i mean if you're if you're gonna
drape someone in in in
in the word patriot this guy is it holy
[ __ ] um so adam points this video out
and mike wendell well he's a little
crazy he's a crazy kook he sits around
his underwear talking to the phone the
trader tv
um josh marshall tweets that a lawyer
for the gop governor
the candidate
recently arrested for j6 crimes tells
judge he still needs to keep his guns
while under indictment you guys know
that i think his name is ryan kelly and
then his name ryan kelly
he sounds like a
college quarterback or something that
the name ryan kelly uh is running for
governor and i think he's a front-runner
in the republican primary this guy is
poised to be the republican nominee
which is not surprising that a
seditionist a traitor would would be the
top contender to be on the republican
ticket
but this guy
apparently he was arrested on federal
charges for january 6
um and the judge when you're when you're
on pre-trial and federal uh
crimes like all the january six uh
insurrectionists some of them go home
with an ankle monitor some
sit in jail but the one thing that the
they don't let you do is travel or have
guns like that that's something that you
like you got to get permission
uh we've seen that several times with uh
some of these insurrectionists where
they've requested
to travel
um but here this guy is requesting to
keep his guns
yeah so we'll see what happens with that
i doubt the judge is going to let a
sedition issue try to overturn the
government have their guns i made a cry
face
push snowflake
poor snowflake
michael beschloss points out a good
point here
about mike pence like i was saying
earlier michael beschloss tweets if
pence quote never wavered then why did
he call up dan quayle to ask whether
there was any way he could go along with
trump's
demand to fix the 2020 election for
trump exactly
why was he looking for a reason to do it
if he never wavered
he wavered up until the very moment get
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] mike
pence listen
again this the images of him in the
parking garage when he finally made the
commitment that he would save democracy
he finally made that commitment
finally
when he when he was in that parking
garage with the cell phone the piece of
paper and the pen those are stark images
now the vice president trying to hold
together our government
and crazy stuff
but don't make mike pence into some kind
of hero from the beginning yeah he he
made the right decision he did the right
thing he didn't commit a crime okay
let's applaud him for not committing the
crime that the criminals wanted him to
commit
come on
that's what everyone should have been
doing
mayo tweets mayo is one of our favor
here good morning to everyone who can't
wait for donald trump to be penniless
and in prison we're almost to the
penniless part
we're almost there to the penniless part
and you know the true social sucks that
ain't making no [ __ ] money over there
his his business is about to go down
they got a testify here here soon
uh in front of tish james's team and
take down the trump organization they're
gonna crack that up with a hammer
and and just like they did trump
university and the trump fund that the
trump
foundation the
fraudulent charity that they had they
broke that up with a hammer
so they're gonna break up their money
laundering machine so i mean he's gonna
be penniless before you know it why do
you think he keeps grifting
his supporters for
for donations about election fraud and
[ __ ]
he's [ __ ] gay
oh my god
this is hilarious so you guys we we've
had walter on walter matthews and i know
you guys probably know walter has funny
videos that he does where he goes and
goofs on the maga
and he's had several he's he went
you guys seen one of the most famous
ones is where he goes on the beach with
matt gatz and marjorie taylor green and
the reason why it's so infamous is
because that's the picture we have of
marjorie taylor green's feet and why we
know she may have three maybe four toes
it's really weird her feet look really
weird in that in that picture but that's
one of the reasons why we have it
is walter pointed out because he whitney
trolled matt gatz right yeah i don't
believe you're a pedophile but that's
that's a really famous video
but walter was at january sixth he was
at he was at the capitol that day he
even told us in an interview that he was
outside
i mean a guy came out
and and said yeah someone's been shot in
there and showed them the video of of
ashley babbitt being shot and that's
when walter's like [ __ ] this [ __ ] we're
out of here because he was down there
trying to get trying to like he does he
holds a microphone and he goofs on these
people tries to get interviews with
these people that's what he does
he's done it for a long time he's a
comedian
he's trying to make comedy and what
better way than to hold a microphone in
front of a maga mouth breather but uh
walter says here the viral video i
posted
myself he posted this video is being
treated as uncovered footage
quote unquote by q anons
that i was behind january 6. walter
it's all walter's fault by the way it's
all walter
here's the thing walter was actually in
the footage for january 6. if you guys
were paying attention yesterday there
was one point when they were playing
footage from january 6
and there was a man standing there with
a mask on and a hat and some camouflage
and he had an oan microphone and he was
interviewing
one of the trump supporters that was
laying siege on the capitol
that was walter that was walter trying
to kind of create comedy
but this person this account here
decides that this is real real footage
of antifa here oh yeah
this is real footage of antifa
tricking people
and and
actually creating the
insurance i don't know i can't figure
out what they're trying to say that this
is uncovered footage it's hilarious
the satire and parody in here is
hilarious
watch walter as he's preparing
to go
goof on these magalidites at the capitol
he's getting his disguise on okay so
this
i'm gonna wear a mask underneath the
mask
you should wear this i'm wondering if i
should wear what do you think i should
wear with the hair should wear this
yeah um here this is your mask oh my god
the american mask
dude i'm not i'm not [ __ ] with you
you gotta blend in i know you can't
stomach wearing it but like you need to
blend it you have to have a visual
identifier
i am not you're not coming if you're not
wearing this all right
you could also wear this yeah the the
america hat might be my move but we'll
see we'll keep i'll bring them both in
my backpack we've got
boxers
i don't know if we're committing crimes
doing this but you know like we're are
you insinuating that i don't work for
all three of these companies
simultaneously i am at least a little
bit insinuating that you feel like you
think that i don't
work
for all of them they they won't trust
you unless there's a visual like there's
something visual
i want to bring in gabe sanchez here uh
because gabe knows walter we freaked out
yesterday when we seen that footage of
course we were we were kind of behind
the scenes right we were right right
yeah it was the yeah as soon as as soon
as i heard
walter speak and i saw the profile i was
like oh i know that bandana and i know
that voice and i immediately sent a
message to walter and i was like holy
[ __ ] you're i was like you're you're
you are now entered into the record that
is so [ __ ] awesome because we've
talked to walter about january 6. like
he he describes to us in our interview
about like and maybe we should go repost
that or something on youtube so people
can see that entire interview but walter
talks about an interview where he was
visited by the fbi because he had a lot
of footage from that day because he was
down there goofing on them with a camera
and and fake microphones as this video
shows but
the the important thing to remember here
is that when he got visited by the fbi
he was not at his house right they he
was at a he was at a friend's house and
they showed up and they were like we're
looking for walter and they're like what
the [ __ ] yeah so you gotta well maybe
today we'll go repost that interview i i
don't know if we have enough but but
we'll we'll post that over the weekend
or something we'll show you guys that
way you guys can go watch walter talk
about
january because we asked him a lot about
january 6 and some of the rallies and
stuff that he went to but january 6 he
had a lot of good stories one of the
stories that i just said on air is he
found out ashley babbitt was shot from
someone who walked outside and showed
him a video on their phone and he's like
the hell with this and he left when
someone right yeah they never they never
entered the capitol right they were just
they were on the lawn and on the steps
area and you know they enough where they
could see what was happening
uh for people going in but they never
actually entered the capital right well
and again that's why the fbi um
apparently if you go watch the interview
and talks to walters because they're
really looking i think they're looking
for his footage more than anything
right but this this this account here
there's what they say this is hilarious
more footage on antipa changing into
patriot gears
to storm the u.s capitol on jan six
that was set up by nancy pelosi like
what evidence in this video gives you
any kind of indication number one that
this is antifa other than this is
clearly walter matterson well this is
the second time this has happened the
first time happened when it was the uh
it was the infowars crew and they were
like oh my god you guys won't believe
this we figured out these guys were
antifa it wasn't actually republicans it
wasn't actually magga it was the left it
was antifa it was blm that's what they
kept pushing and he's like
you guys realize
that i'm a comedian like i publicly
posted this posted this stuff and i've
handed said materials over to the fbi
right right but you guys are like
breaking news and then it's another
person who's like oh my god you won't
believe this and everyone's like this is
what you you you can't be serious right
now you think that this guy
is trying is antifa and he's trying to
infiltrate the capital
he's [ __ ] goofing on you all
and you're just an example of someone
who fell for it
well here's walter um's reaction to him
being on because he was he was
apparently he says i was trolling the
january 6 hearing and they were
livestreaming he was on twitch right
right i think so and realized i'm
featured as evidence this is my
real-time reaction so here's a
screenshot here's avalar speaking here
and you see walter
um you know they're goofing on fox news
here is what they're doing on twitch um
which is what walter does but watch his
reaction when he pops up on the screen
watch what happens when he realizes that
he is part
of history here
that's very hard to hear but here's what
the president wrote in his 2 24 pm tweet
while the violence at the capitol is
going on
and here's what the writers thought so
right now they're going to cut to
uh someone interviewing one of the quote
unquote writers
right i think it's a little creepy that
they're even saving these tweets right
like who does it he's not even oh my god
that's me
oh my god it is
is that me yeah that's you
is that me that's you
he's like i know it's me because he it's
his video right it's his videos like is
that is that me because but i'm sure i
would do the same thing if i saw my
video up on the big screen i'm like wait
what what january is what yeah no no
[ __ ] way guys like i would probably
have the same reaction to see that in
real time be like wait no no they get
holy [ __ ] they use my [ __ ] right he's
part of the historical evidence here
yeah he's part of historical evidence
and if you notice what's funny about
this is he's holding an oan microphone
which is the thing that he had in the
bag right right right yeah he was like
yeah he was like which one should i use
fox news oan newsmax he had a he had uh
him because he because he uses those to
trick to trick them and they're talking
into the microphone and here's the thing
too they in a detail that people might
know but might not know about is they
released these videos and newsmax
actually came after them or maybe it was
oan i forget which one i think about
newsmax but they came after them because
the another person that was with walter
they switched i think they might have
switched mics as well but they came back
and said that they could not
uh post this video on youtube so the
video had like blown up and then one of
the two uh outlets oan or newsmax came
out and was like this is ours you can't
have it and it became this like back and
forth with them and they eventually like
actually
news outlet you don't own this property
this is theirs and then
they got put back onto you or like you
know released back onto youtube
i got you i didn't get you well
it it if you notice the the
the outfit there
that outfit
is
is the outfit that he was in the prior
video that we were watching where they
think he's
hired by pelosi to go down here and
goof on these guys i i don't know i'm
not really sure
well i mean like you know it's one of
the it's it's the classic uh
i'm not willing to accept reality you
know it's you know what it's very
trump-like right right i'm not willing
to accept the reality despite the fact
that uh it is illegal it's not actually
yeah and then so it's like oh you know
what i'm not i don't want to uh believe
what happened i want to even though i
was there right even though this person
might have been there and done something
illegal they were like no no no the
actual person who was the the
perpetrator the actual bad person was
antifa antifa made me do it and it's
like what do you mean antifa woke you up
in the morning told you weeks beforehand
that you should show up
and then it was told you that you should
make a weapon out of a flagpole i don't
think so auntie didn't do that
well i mean
these people will believe just about
anything and i think that's one of the
main pieces of evidence that we're
seeing that they're trying to undo is
that these people still believe the big
lie right right and that's brings me to
my next video about january 6 and the
big lie no one's a bigger liar than jim
jordan here
there's a lot about this video because
and i may have to play it a couple times
here but have you seen this video yet
gabe of him talking about and now this
is again now this is an actual interview
with oan we see here it isn't it isn't a
guy like walter holding annoying i have
not i have not seen this video yet so
this is on aon coverage here um but this
is jim jordan with his reaction on oan
so remember the context here of january
6 let's watch it congressman jordan your
name came up quite a few times in the
january 6 committee hearing
and uh i'm wondering what you make of
this hearing so far a couple days uh
what seems to be going on i don't know
that we've learned anything new i mean
um you know we knew we already knew they
were
a goal okay so let's stop in there
so
so number one
if maybe jim jordan hasn't actually
learned anything new that's what i'm
surprised yeah maybe he was like i
already because remember jim jordan is
the same person who was unable to tell
any news publication how many times or
when he spoke to donald trump on january
6th his answer was like um um uh well
it's um
it's uh um
uh uh well like okay so like a phone
what's a phone call what's a phone call
mystery it depends on what your
definition of a phone call
is
is well it's it's really funny because
they all they all know that they were in
big trouble because they were oh yeah
they were continuing to you remember
that the hearing where josh hawley and
mike lee are like so
what kind of data did the fbi like
they're questioning the director of the
fbi like what kind of data did you
collect inside the cap they're like all
of it
like do you mean like all of it all of
it or just like all of it other than us
wait wait wait what do you mean that our
cell phones have become tracking beacons
he goes right well yeah well that's just
typically how the building works we
can't have a security risk so once you
enter in we have your [ __ ] location
on your phone so that if we ever do
something in the future or you come back
we know exactly who you are we know
exactly where to pinpoint you in the
building on footage
it's crazy that that that they were
asking these questions right so so if i
were to
get rid of my cell phone right now with
that and they're like why are you asking
that question you're right you're right
there's no right no reason no reason no
reason right no reason literally uh
throw that out now right right yeah burn
it burn it
like we you're still hot on the mic we
can still hear what you're saying
what i mean here's the thing is jim
jordan apparently has learned nothing
from this hearing so he knew
he knew the trump uh the the election
defense fund didn't exist he knew that
the proud boys wanted to kill mike pence
he he knew that mike pence was looking
for a way to overturn the election he
couldn't find a viable legal way that
would keep him out of criminal trouble
because i believe that's actually the
story they wanted to make him into a
hero yesterday but i leave i believe
mike pence was truly looking for a way
to not commit a crime and still do what
donald trump wanted to do right um
but that's just my my opinion yeah i
mean it would be crazy if we were able
to you know recover those uh
what seven hours
right
seven hours of the seven hour gap in
time of the phone records right i mean
over the visitor log right right well i
i i don't be surprised if jim jordan was
in that gap right well let's listen to
what else he says here because this is
he he really it's almost like he's not
watching these things and doesn't have
to watch because he knew the whole plan
in the first place right
stop president trump from running again
um they went in the electoral college
um so they had hundreds of witnesses
thousands of hours anyone discussed
getting rid of the electoral college so
so he's talking he's he's dumbing it
down for these viewers on oan because
they were talking about yesterday the
act that the the law that sets forth
those electoral laws right
and
no one said yesterday that they want to
get rid of it like right i mean i think
it's worth that it's worth a shot to
look at it to make sure no one can
commit a coup
i mean it's worth at least examining
that law that was written in the 1800s
at least it's crazy it's almost like
it's a it's part of a living document
right that's supposed to be organic
and evolving right and changing over
time because
there's no way that the founding fathers
could have said oh yeah uh in these
hundreds of years later or after the
fact we totally predict
how we how our society is going to be
and how this document shouldn't be laid
out again i think i think there is a way
to look at that document and i think
that's what they're saying i think
that's what the committee is going to
suggest here to examine now rather we
can actually get real movement on that
right is is another thing but you know
that's up to everyone out there
listening to go vote and to engage to
vote people in who want to look at these
policies and really say maybe we should
take this seriously now let's listen to
what else uh unserious jim i don't
report sex crimes jordan says and they
have two hearings and i don't know that
we like i said we learned anything we
didn't know already so
didn't he anything we know already he's
like because i already knew everything i
already knew who i was talking to i was
already knew what i was supposed to do
you know i already knew they were
supposed to kill
mike pence no big deal you know we're
gonna get to bonehead of the week here
soon but boy this guy this guy just like
the rest of these chuckleheads these
knuckle draggers could be
on bone end of the week every single
week every single week let's let's
listen um i think the big takeaway is
there's no pushback there's no
cross-examination there's no there's no
chance to
hear anything from from from a different
perspective you mean from the trader's
perspective right like what are you
talking about what perspective do you
need right i don't know you're asking
questions they want alternative factors
right they're answering questions who's
going to come in and be like well blah
blah blah blah blah like who's going to
come in and give the alternative
the cross-examination
i i don't right what is the alternative
yeah what is this
so this person died oh
i don't think they did and it's like
well no no man some of these people like
like this um this cowboys for trump guy
that's supposed to get sentenced today
he's a county commissioner in new mexico
we're talking about him earlier he's the
cowboy he's again where's the hat he
hates seth macfarlane because seth
macvarlane reports on him
but this guy this guy is supposed to be
sentenced today but this guy
they were um i think it was maybe
someone i think was a good liars had a
video that they were asking him rather
he believes that brian sicknick is still
alive he's like i think he's still alive
it's possible that officer is not really
dead he faked his death i'm like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about you
people are
out of your minds we're gonna do bone
end of the week here we got uh we got a
great bone end of the week um this week
so uh everyone stick around we're gonna
go to break here real quick and then
when we come back
we will get into bone end of the week
stick around don't go anywhere bone of
the week right after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
[Music]
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day i'm
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw can't wait
another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome along and welcome back to the
show thanks for sticking through the
break
the trump fund
we know now it's real we know the pardon
blankets are real
gabe was bright spot on he was correct
bone head speaking of bone heads
we have now reached the point in the
week for bone end of the week
gabe
boom i'm excited about this bone end of
the week i really am man i don't want to
say first i want to say two commercials
today the two commercials today you made
those videos a long time ago but we have
seen that the evidence that has been
laid out with the january 6 select
committee in the public all the way back
and this is a year and a half ago 2016
2018 november 2020
the pardon blanket we know there's lines
for pardons and and we know that the
truth i call it
on online yesterday i called it the uh
trump's pardon buffet and i said how
many people are online and there were
some pretty good responses somebody said
uh
kushner was taking the orders
of the line you know oh well he was he
was bragging about the pardons
right
he was like
i'm helping some people i'm helping good
people out but he's also like i'm
helping not good people right right i'm
trying to get some pardons here there's
a whole list of them you should see the
members of somebody somebody
now i imagine this moment like a
ballpark where you're at you know and
you're like yeah well you know normally
he's like yeah get a hot dog here get
your hot dog you know cold beer cold
beer and then someone's like pardons get
your party does anybody want a party
like that is we don't talking that is
kushner hawking pardons to anyone well
you know that we we even seen evidence
like
back then during the end of january
right before the like the people were
paying people to go pen pardons like
roger stone apparently was paid to pimp
a pardon for now now pleading guilty
joel greenberg matt gatz's venmo friend
right right exactly i mean that's he was
the he was the he was like uh he was
like a pardon coyote almost right he was
like listen i'll get you safely across
the border in which we go from guilty
you just pay me a bunch of to completely
safe and immune with a pardon
seems funny that roger stone would have
a personal phone line for pardons
like hello this is the pardon hotline
maybe that's what the burners were for
maybe that's what the burners were for
but in my mind now i'm just thinking of
the old like telephones like hello this
is pardon hotline how am i like i don't
know why all these people i'm doing
impressions of are just old hawk and
[ __ ] right right right it's well yeah i
just imagine on the line and go through
the um
the uh
uh the hotline route and the person on
the other end is like let me just let me
just they're like let me just let me
just patch it through hold on he's like
boom boom they just put the wire into
the next like like yes hello this is
roger stone here i'm here to give you a
pardon how many you are you want 10 10
000 10 000 on party one like almost even
as if he's like taking bets like a like
a bookie saying
what uh what betsy's like listen we've
got a bid for ten thousand oh looks like
we got another guy sliding in uh he's
hedging his bets with ten thousand and
two hundred dollars
like that's
so like taking bids on pardons yeah
essentially
i mean really it is like you're going
through an operator and then
you've got him on the other line he's
like taking down these bets
for how much you're willing to pay for
gabe sanchez always right on top of
these boneheads always has him right in
the satire and write in his sights
with truth right to power with comedy
and speaking of boneheads let's go to
bone end of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
gabe bonehead of the week
i was very surprised i was very
surprised by this vote
uh we see the twitter vote here
herschel walker won the twitter vote he
won the twitter vote however
however
he did not win the youtube vote
as a result right we have maybe a
different bonehead we have a different
i'm not trying to give it away but this
was surprising to me because it was very
close the the the percentage difference
i won't say who won
but the percentage different was 2.2
right and we're not trying to rig the
vote here or anything where we go by the
numbers
people wanted youtube to throw it into
the mix and now we have an eclectic
diverse it's almost like we have two
states two states
two two electors here that we're working
with with the popular vote in mind
because here's the thing folks you guys
vote every single week go to twitter at
tonymichaelspod or you can vote here on
youtube do not forget to subscribe to
the youtube channel because you can vote
in both places for bonehead of the week
every single week and then we break it
down right here on bone of the week for
you
but today was a little strange because
one one one place and the other one the
other place and
we had to certify the vote
i know we had to certify you know
luckily you know i did have to kind of
fend off
my my home you know from uh from a bunch
of people who were unwilling to really
accept the results
there might of this
an insurrection there almost
why are you receiving i got a call from
i see from dan quayle and he said
you know how to spell coup and then he
spelled it for me did he spell it wrong
did he spell it c-o-o-p
at first he was like c
yeah oh
you
he got it he got it by the end there he
finally he finally spelled goo right
everyone knows that dan guell is famous
for not being able to spell potato
potato
and that's the guy who may have saved
democracy
speaking of people who didn't try to
save democracy uh here we have who tried
to overthrow democracy here we have a
couple people because herschel walker
would love to be part of the next
overthrow oh yeah he's trying his best i
mean i wouldn't i wouldn't doubt this
guy already begins to throw in the idea
that this thing was rigged this election
in georgia isn't gonna go my way so i
might as well pull a trump and say guys
the only way that i lose is if
the other guys cheat
yeah herschel what do you think he's
that smart though i don't know no i mean
he's going to talk about an organization
of men that's watching women that's
watching votes
what tick tock you know is that a
government agency is that he said he
said it it's a real thing he said if
there's a government agency that of men
watching women
people take
these people seriously it's yeah i don't
know they drank the kool-aid man and
they you know they took out another
mortgage on their home and they paid in
to the trump election fund and then they
found out that it was not a real thing
and they all got scammed and they said
hey
where do i sell my car to get cash
to give you more money trumpy baby
herschel walker a guy who lives in texas
who's a carpetbagger who didn't graduate
from uga who was not in the fbi who did
not invent the wheel and did not invent
the internet um but he did he did
herschel walker invented
c t e oh well that's positive or at
least he first discovered it right that
could be that could be well he's
probably a doctor too and speaking of
fake doctors we have senator rand paul
on our list as well um senator rand paul
of course we know trends every now and
then because he's a dumb [ __ ] yeah um
and yesterday was
no no surprise that he was trending um
we me and you watched the video because
he started to trend we were like we're
like who's the bone end of the week we
were trying to figure this out and they
were like oh of course he did something
right rand paul was trending and what
the funniest part is is gabe asked me
before we went and before we went and
seen exactly why he was trending he said
why is ram vulturing i said i don't know
probably something some stupid [ __ ] he
said to fauci and i mean
you can't you can guess exactly
at this point it's now always going to
be about fouchy like if there ever was
if there ever was a story of two
villains or like two rivals right and
it's like what's your villain origin
story and rand paul's like as soon as
fouchy was born i knew there was a
disruptance in the in in
in in the earth and i had to go against
him and now his whole thing is he go you
know he's like i'm a doctor and he tries
to go and dance about you at any point
he tries to go to an actual dog you know
it's funny in this clip here because
rand paul and and all the [ __ ] the
fouchy obsessed right wing far right
people who think he's some kind of i
don't know what the hell they think he
is some i i just can't figure it out
some kind of demon or some [ __ ] but he
he's accusing dr fauci of of owning um
uh uh patents right which he does
because he he is he is a doctor and he
does work in a lab and he does develop
things for medicine
that end up being patents for different
medicine and things and that's how that
works right
and generally if you have a patent you
might or might not get paid for it
depends on the situation yeah and
sometimes it could be a shitload of
money right we know there's a [ __ ] it
also depends on how many people are on
the patent so that's right you could be
like one person or it could be a team of
people right it could be dozens and
dozens of people that actually quote
unquote own this patent because they
were you're getting royalties like you
would in any other thing now here
senator rand paul in this clip is asking
for some proof
and he and he really steps in here when
dr fauci
gives him the yeah just watch just watch
jesus christ all the distribution of
money in research grants
um well first of all let's talk about
roy that's the question no that's the
question have you ever overseen him
won't even let him answer if what do you
let him talk and the reason why
rand paul won't want dr fancy talk is
because he's gonna hand him his ass
right i mean that's the reason why rand
paul knows the gig here rand paul knows
he's lying he knows he's exaggerating
[ __ ] because yes dr fauci does make
money and patents he does and he makes
money in research that's what he does
that's part of his work that he does
but it is it is disingenuous for rand
paul to say anything anymore about dr
fauci like anything at all right is
disingenuous never received a royalty
payment from a company yeah that you
later oversaw money going to that
company
you know i don't know as a fact but i
doubt it well now here's the thing is
why don't you let us know
gotcha
how much you've gotten ha ha i mean dr
factory is like do you have any idea how
many because he probably is on like you
said teams for those patents
in a lab of people right and he's
probably on hundreds of them right yeah
and there's some that he's probably on
that he's not even really fully aware of
like it's an old patent and he he really
didn't have a lot of research work to do
with it but because he had something to
do with it he's placed on that patent
right yep and and somehow somehow rand
paul thinks because dr fauci had
my new thing to do with some patent
somewhere that's making no money because
that's something that that [ __ ]
fouchy's gonna show you here is that
yeah yeah you're talking about money
okay we'll show you how much money but
again they're making they're making
they're trying to make mountains out of
out of molehills here right let's let's
listen and from what entities the nih
refuses look we ask them we ask them the
nih we ask them whether or not who got
it and how much they refused to tell us
they sent it redacted here's what i want
to know it's not just about you
everybody on the vaccine committee have
any of them ever receive money from the
people who make vaccines can you tell me
that can you tell me if anybody on the
vaccine approval comes if you let him
[ __ ] talk
questions sound bite number one are you
gonna let me answer a question
this is great let me give you some
information first of all according to
the regulations people who receive
royalties are not required to divulge
them even on their financial statement
according to the buy dole act so let me
give you some example from
2015 to 2020
i the only warranties i have
was my lab and i made a monoclonal
antibody for use in vitro reagent that
had nothing to do with patients
and during that period of time now wait
for it because he's going to tell you
how much money he made everyone get
ready to know how rich
how rich dr fauci is from this patent
hold on to your seat here you're gonna
find out
my royalties range from 21 a year
to 17 700 a year and the average per
year here we go was 191
cents
he's really rolling in it you know it
would almost be like it would almost be
like rand paul who takes money from a
lot of [ __ ] people even makes money
selling stock and buying stock during
the pandemic or like maybe makes money
from russia
right right all kinds of [ __ ] you think
this guy would be like whoa 152 bucks
some [ __ ] you could buy a steak dinner
with that this guy yeah i mean that is
it's honestly like oh what can we buy
with this it's like well look look we
can go all out and they're like oh my
god what can we buy and he's like a a
very nice dinner right you know he's
like wait wait wait you're not making
thousands he's not making millions he's
like no actually you know i'm making as
little as 21 dollars
a year that's not not like a minute not
like everything right
a year you're like that's like a couple
sandwiches worth and it's like i mean
you can maybe get three if you go to
subway you know right this is ridiculous
the best part of this video is to come
though
it's all red it's all redacted and you
can't get any information on the 1800
scientist your time is so we want to
know whether or not people got money
from the people who made the manual
senator paul your time is long over
expired i gave you an additional two and
a half minutes the witness has responded
we are going to move on so i i actually
missed it in here let's let's see this
because we asked him this is not the
clip that we saw yesterday whether or
not it isn't
no because when he says sound bite
number one it's on fouchy but he says it
here and it's still on ran it's still on
paul
oh i see i see i gotta find where that
clip was yeah i know because he calls
him senator sound bite doesn't he and
nobody calls it well he goes no because
he goes sound bite number one
he might have well he might have been
like senator and then he said sound bite
and he goes
i sure he was calling it out like this
shit's gonna be used against me sound
bite number one
can you let me answer the question i
swore he called him senator soundbite
here's another but it might have been
another copy
we got to look for this in research
payment from a company that you later
oversaw money going to that company
you know i don't know as a fact but i
doubt it well now here's the thing is
why don't you let us know why don't you
reveal how much you've gotten and from
what entities the nih refuses look we
ask them we ask them the nih we asked
them whether or not who got it and how
much they refused to tell us they sent
it redacted here's what i want to know
it's not just about you everybody on the
vaccine committee have any of them ever
receive money from the people who make
vaccines can you tell me that can you
tell me if anybody on the vaccine
approval committees ever received any
money from people's
questions
sound bite number one are you going to
let me answer a question there it is
sound bite number one i thought he
called i know he was just trying to get
like senator you're going to let me
finish and then he was like sound bite
number one are you going to let me
finish
rand paul senator sound bite because
that's totally what he is and totally i
mean like that's i mean here's the thing
you look at like one is what was the
committee hearing for what was the
hearing for and what was he answering
questions about and like was the
questions that he had
even remotely related to what was
happening and even if it was
he's already answered the question and
already told him i make [ __ ] 21 at
the low end 700 on the high end and on
average i'm making
120 to 150 bucks or whatever it was
enough to
buy
some nice
meal maybe if that that's like not even
covering the tip and that's like a meal
for one like if i were to go to like the
the capitol club
and go buy a meal like that would
probably be the lunch
oh my god
i i would imagine that uh the way that
ran senator soundbyte rand paul does his
hair it probably cost about 125 bucks oh
dude i would say that perms are not are
not cheap has got to be at least 150
perm man yeah i mean you can't get it
wet you know i i learned most of what i
know about perms from legally blonde so
you know i am an expert i would say
that's good that's good senator
soundbyte from inch forth henceforth
will be known here on the tony michael's
podcast but you could also say all of
the republican representatives and like
congressmen and senators or senator or
like you know congressman or
representative sound bite senator sound
bite like that's what they are because
that's what they're doing they're just
trying to create fake outrage and
they're trying to say hey i need my
sound my 15 minutes of
of spotlight or a fame on newsmax or on
or fox news or whatever [ __ ] network
because i want to be like gotcha [ __ ]
and really it's like no you didn't you
didn't get him well let's talk about a
gotcha [ __ ] moment um for someone who
wants to be a senator sound bite
herschel walker ooh
you i i questioned yesterday you were
like no we need to put herschel walker
on yeah and i was like why father's day
is this sunday what's the what's the
what's why why would we put hershel
walker do you have a clip that we could
play or something that i could show you
so why
why we're putting him on the list
because i was really unaware of this i
have been paying attention to our
hearing in some of the production now
everyone knows
that gabe
is
christian walker herschel walker's uh
son that he actually acknowledges that
is his son apparently
um he's his virtual roommate on the
internet um not actual roommate but you
know kind of parody type right right
yeah on the internet they're they're
maybe based on a video we're about to
play there may be a video coming out
where i'm just trying to talk to my
roommate you know because you know
father's day is on sunday it is it is on
sunday a lot of people in the beginning
of the show or said they're going to
celebrate father's day and juneteenth on
because it's a duel it's a dual day um
right there but uh but what video are
you gonna show us here what is this um
so this is a video that was released uh
let's let me look up really quick when
the actual release date of this video
was this is christian walker right do i
have to play the whole 50 seconds of
this your roommate here or just the
phone you don't
you don't have to play the whole okay
because i really this i mean you could
play the whole thing but you don't have
to play the whole thing your roommate is
really he's he's a piece of [ __ ] work
this is um definitely a character
but you're going to make a video based
but i'm going to make a video that might
be more kind of um
digestible okay so so everyone it's five
527 is when he released that video wait
wait wait this year yeah yeah this is
this year so this 527 this is within the
last month
one two three uh yeah like three and a
half weeks ago oh okay so it sounds like
he knew news was coming maybe
maybe he's definitely doing high
projection here but on on this take it's
something
let's let's watch it here and see what
we got fathers it would be great if you
stayed home and raised your kids instead
of ran off to bang a bunch of women who
weren't your baby mama stay home and
raise your freaking kids your kids need
a father get back home get back home if
you take out your thing and you get a
woman pregnant guess what the party days
are over the acting foolish days are
over you go get a freaking job and you
support your new
family get home
okay okay okay
the reason the reason why the reason why
this this is uh i guess newsworthy that
this [ __ ] chucklehead is yelling and
screaming the same thing over and over
and number one he's talking about he's
alluding to abortions i think here yeah
he's yeah he's talking about abortions
and he's talking about how uh but the
funny part is is with the recent news i
think that's what you're getting yeah
yeah yeah so
if we go back
earlier this week right i believe it was
that's like centuries ago gabe that's
like i know i know i think i want to say
it was tuesday maybe okay wednesday
maybe maybe wednesday is there only one
baby revealed because we knew that it
was tony tony if there's one there's
more
you find out that he has uh a secret 10
year old uh child who who
christian
no her herschel oh okay so christian has
has a sibling is what you're saying yeah
yeah he's got a sibling now whether he
knew about that sibling or not i don't
know it seems a little bit weird that he
would make a video like that if he
actually didn't know about it but then
again i wouldn't be surprised if he did
know about it and then maybe that's when
he found out maybe that's exactly i know
here's the thing as much as herschel
walker says i love my son i love my son
i mean herschel walker's also on his way
which one which one
the sun yeah well he's like i don't i
love my one son
christian walker he says he said he
claimed before this one
he's claimed before and talked about now
the other thing to remember here is that
christian walker
is gay yeah but herschel walker has also
talked about he doesn't really support
the gay community or the right to get
married
so these are things that contradict the
beliefs that his own son has which is
very hypocritical or it just doesn't
feel right for someone that's it doesn't
even
walkers say really
really some vile stuff about about
people who are in the lgbtq community
he calls them all he says they're
liberal trash and he calls them ghetto
ghetto liberals and he says uh blue hair
you know blue hair liberal girl and all
this [ __ ] and there's like oh and
then he obviously he's very transphobic
he does not support trans people
doesn't support them being involved in
sports which again is like point zero
something percent in terms of what the
actual breakdown of people who
may have been male and transition to
female and then participated in a
female-led sport right and so it's a lot
of people projecting their own
insecurities and their own kind of
worries on to other people and worrying
about their own lives which is very on
brand for republicans which is like let
me enter your home and tell you how to
live your life especially a social media
influencing republican exactly who
that's all they do is spout hate so
let's get back to herschel walker so we
found out he had one
unknown child we found out he had one
one unknown child and then
and then it was revealed
that he had additional
unknown children that were secrets how
many how many and i believe the numbers
at three right now
[Laughter]
should you should we start making a
graph like a thermometer where you i
only fill up the thermometer of how many
uh unknown children yeah yeah so
yeah so it's got to be a lot because
christian walker was saying it over and
over again right
every time he said you know right maybe
baby mama whatever but the other thing
is really important is because hershel
walker has commented and said that the
issues that happen within our society
are based on fatherless homes
so he's attacked people who are
fatherless
and he's made home's father and he's
made homes
that's fatherless which again is
completely on brand with the republican
party
and be hypocrites but what happened was
wednesday secret child was revealed you
know name anonymous obviously and the
mother anonymous which good and then we
find out on thursday that two more
unknown children have been added to the
herschel walker secret kids club this
isn't like these are young children too
right these are really yeah i mean this
is recent
the one one of which is 10. right
christian walker is 22
uh the third one is 13.
and
it looks like he has another
different these are different women or
these are it looks like different women
so you've got one woman who had a boy
who's 10. then you had another person
who had a child who's 13
out of
if you having different partners and you
end up having different children you
know
i just i just think it goes back to the
hypocrisy of it all you say these shitty
things and your roommate says these
shitty things [ __ ] these
and the other one is a 20 year old
daughter so he's got three sons and one
daughter but christian up until this
week is the only one that well that's
the only one that everyone acknowledged
and that's the only one that he
acknowledged and that's the one you know
and the other the other thing too is
that the party with their you know his
campaign you know his team was like oh
we've never not acknowledged his other
children he loves them all the same
don't try to politicize this and it's
like it's a bit of an issue if you've
never actually acknowledged them and
then the day that they come out in terms
of being revealed that they were secret
children out of wedlock then you're like
i i love all my children all the same
and that's how it was for the first kid
and then two additional kids came out
gabe
maybe maybe there's something we just
don't know about hershel walker maybe he
invented cloning and these are clones
children i'm just saying i mean
you know what was it golly the sheep
right yep yeah well
maybe he was that maybe not only was the
inventory but he was the inventor of
cloning and he was the one that actually
ended the wheel he invented the internal
combustion engine um
which which i don't know who
passed walker here because uh
[ __ ] him i guess you would say he is a
bonehead but where's where's the um the
dm we got this uh dishonorable mention
ken paxton what was what was the reason
why he was on the list is there a
certain reason yeah as dm yeah i put him
as dm because ken paxton decided to give
his two cents
on the victims of uvalde where he said
god or some [ __ ] he said god has a plan
and you know life is short and
it is what it is which again very on
brand republicans to be like we care
about republic we care about lives and
then only to say yeah well you know it's
god's plan like this isn't this isn't
like some [ __ ] drake song okay this
is actual these are actual people actual
children
that have lives that matter but to him
he's talking about the uvaldi deaths and
specifically salon has a quote here of
texas attorney general kim paxton who is
uh
incrim
being investigated on criminal charges
on the udavali death god has a plan
shannon watts tweeted texas your current
attorney general thinks the answer to
mass shootings is god has a plan and
armed teachers
if you want an actual plan to address
uh gun violence please uh follow and
support raquel uh garza is that is that
are they running
um oh yeah she is she is running i don't
know she running uh she's running for
attorney general in in texas um is what
shannon is pointing out here so um yeah
he said god has a plan you know what i i
remember this because i tweeted
um
i tweeted i think i tweeted at ken
paxton i believe i i don't know if he
posted something or something i think i
tweeted at him uh you can take your god
and stick it up your ass like if this is
if this is the god's plan that you had
you can take that and stick it up your
ass uh what's this link you sent me here
so that's the actual audio clip so if
you want to have him that's him
that that is ken paxton
uh being a shitty human being okay well
let's play this and then we'll move on
to the alpha because we got to get to
the winner here yeah yeah uh let's see
okay so we've got
to do
let's let's pull this up and for anyone
who doesn't know ken paxton is the
attorney general for texas he's also the
guy that this is this is just audio
right it's a video but just audio yeah
yeah okay yeah we'll just play it here
listen
it might give a little comfort
like i think it's it it's difficult to
give comfort if i lost one of my
children i'd be pretty devastated
uh especially in in a way that is so
senseless and you know seemingly has no
purpose
uh i think i would say i would just have
to if
i had the opportunity to talk to people
i'd have to say look there's always a
plan i believe god always has a plan
short no matter what i'm ideas yeah
certainly we're not gonna make sense of
yeah okay i can't i can't take any more
of that god has a plan god had a plan to
[ __ ] have this guy go in and right
god has a plan life is short
life is yes life is very [ __ ] short
especially for children especially when
you're louder people go slaughter these
[ __ ] people because you want you want
anyone and everyone to own a gun because
a couple a couple of families in this
country benefit with probably
the the response again the response is
very on brand for republicans and the
gqp where they say i mean it is very
much they're like with that being said
they're like look i am devastated i
would hate if my children were the
victim of gun violence of course they
would now with that being said life is
short and we just got to move on
to these other kids
why are you guys complaining that is
what they're saying that is why they're
upset at the fact that people are upset
that children were slaughtered it's
crazy i shouldn't um we got our alpha
cuck here um uh barry uh louder milk we
know why berry loudermilk is the alpha
cuck here he keeps lying about this tour
that he's giving gabe
at the camera he's changed his story so
many times it went from no tour to i
gave a tour right to a few people then i
gave it to her to a few families and
their friends to i gave a tour to about
16 people okay and yeah they were taking
photos of some weird angles and
stairways and the other thing that the
other thing that because i heard an
interview where he's talking about
because the one guy standing in the
stairwell taking a picture of the stair
he's like oh well there's a railing
there that has a really ornamental thing
that he was taking no
you can tell he's taking a picture up
the st
[ __ ] banister there's also a [ __ ] out
of here
um it was
who was it it was
uh
it was uh representative zoe lofgren and
she said in an interview
they were asking i think it was on msnbc
but they're asking like oh what about
this claim that they were taking a photo
and she's like no one ever takes a
[ __ ] photo of that thing like no
that's not a thing that you take photos
of that's not something that somebody
comes in and goes i'm going to the
capitol and i'm taking a photo of this
gold
object
it's just it's just
they're just making up [ __ ] and the
thing is and then he's talked about the
children wanted to see the tram and all
this yeah like he just
because at first it was i didn't give
any tours
right and then it was like no no my
family was there with me and then he's
like oh well maybe constituents and then
he's like no no no we didn't go these
places and he's like yeah we went there
because of like it just keeps moving the
goalpost i mean it that it's on brand
for these republicans and i didn't know
this barry loudermilk nobody did nobody
knew who this guy was he could have
lived his life in just mediocrity and no
one would have ever known what he was
just a subpar white dude mediocre
that's who he was
and then he decided to enter the chat
and say i never give a tour i never gave
it to her and then he's like okay maybe
i maybe i did give it to her okay i was
a little bit naughty i did give a tour
okay you know what i did give a tour it
was to a group of people oh it's like
what do you want me to like bri not
bring people in before the insurrection
so they don't know how to get around
that would be very unchristian like
[Laughter]
oh my god speaking of people who wanted
to
overthrow our government we do have one
of those another one of those on our
bone of the week he's actually the
winner john eastman we know is
a law professor some obscure guy no one
knew until he tried to commit treason
here and at least that's what it looks
like this guy was trying to
trying to overthrow our government of
the united states and trying to commit
possible violence when he's trying to
get mike pence to do something that mike
pence can't do
and then the violent mob because he was
at the ellipse that day
gabe everyone's like oh john eastman was
just the legal part of it i'm like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] was on the
stage inciting the [ __ ] people who
went to say hang mike pence and they
were calling him out and and
[ __ ]
john eastman is part of the
what created the mob
he wasn't just the guy writing the
[ __ ] memo that's all [ __ ] that's
all [ __ ] him and rudy giuliani stood
on the stage and said in so many words
we have a plan and we need to execute
this i mean remember he was he was also
at the willard hotel the command center
right for the effort to deny biden his
presidency rudy giuliani steve bannon
and christina bob they were all there
trying to coordinate this effort to
overthrow the government of the united
states and when pence told them no they
kept pressuring and kept pressuring
until the very last minute and yes pence
did not break he tried to find a way to
break where he wouldn't be criminally
liable but speaking of crime um and
other officials it seems as if um
well why is that staying there anyways
now let's let's go into the tweet here
there we go there we go uh tristan
schnell has here breaking jeannie thomas
officially served with the letter
requesting her to meet with january 6
committee regarding her communications
with john eastman um they are proposing
july 6 7 8 or the week of the 11th um so
in july
so this is june 16th this is yesterday
that they served our sent i guess uh
jeannie thomas clarence thomas the
supreme court justices wipe a letter
saying we want you to come talk to us
about the information in the john
eastman emails that's really funny
do you remember 2016 there was a
presidential election
there were a lot of people talking about
someone's emails do you remember this
yeah who's the woman i can't remember
the email lady that we had but they
still talk about her over on fox yeah
didn't she go through like 11 hours of
like yeah she did testimony hearings she
did she did go through a lot of hours of
testimony um i can't remember it's
hillary clinton
right but here we actually have an email
lady who's actually trying to overthrow
the government with john eastman now
john eastman still tweets did you know
this i didn't know this stole this
morning john eastman still tweets here
it is here's his twitter account i'm not
[ __ ] you
this is dr john eastman's twitter
account no don't call him doctor don't
that's what it says i'm just well you
know what you know i could say a lot of
things on the internet and it wouldn't
be true that the greatest part here is
former
former constitutional law professor he
isn't any more
he was the dean at chapman university
too i don't know where the hell i think
that's somewhere in california or
something i'd be curious to know how
many people come out of that school
being like oh man i got the best
education on this guy or being like oh
my god please don't ask me about john
eastman please don't ask me about johnny
right like
there's completely embarrassing like
this guy tried to [ __ ] overthrow the
government not only does he have a
twitter he has a sub stack where he
apparently writes about his crimes omg
mrs thomas asked me to give me an update
about election what's the crime here
guys i tried to [ __ ] do a coup okay
what's the big deal this is hilarious
this is hilarious the guy who tried to
overthrow the government with trump
actually in all caps tweets omg he's
supposed to be some kind of
constitutional professor and smart dude
right
omg miss thomas here he's deflecting
here again they're going to keep doing
this stuff they just can't stop you we
seen yesterday this guy
constantly i mean he was saying fifth
before they would finish a question
right did you notice that in summit like
at first he was like uh i have to
believe it
but like before they finish the question
it kind of reminds me of that scene from
dave chappelle show when he's like one
two three four fifth i believe the fifth
yeah it also reminds me of um
obvious trump
right i mean
this was over a hundred times
eastman said i plead the fifth yeah i
mean that's trump did it over 500 times
that's it well
he's five times is better at the fifth
yeah fifth he's fifth better than the
fifth then johnny i don't know this
these guys these guys like jim jordan's
like i we didn't learn anything
yesterday because john eastman played
the fifth a hundred times that's why we
didn't learn anything new that was a
good thing but i mean here john eastman
is can't stop talking about this right
he is he is now placing more evidence on
himself by tweeting this
mrs thomas asked me to give an update
about election litigation to her group
stop the presses like dude stop talking
your way into charges like what the [ __ ]
are you doing
you are criminally exposed because if
you pled fifth in the [ __ ] testimony
what and this is the same thing like you
did a you know what was that or navarro
it's kind of the same thing stop talking
stop these people keep opening their
mouths and giving out the details of
what they did and then they say we did
nothing wrong why do people keep coming
after us no i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
you know follow the subpoena no i'm not
gonna tell you i'm not gonna tell you
under oath what we did but i am willing
to tell ari melbourne what we did on tv
right
but also by the way if you guys can just
buy my book because that's my legal
defense fund and it's going to go
anywhere from a couple hundred to 300 to
500 to a million dollars for a legal
team but i also want to represent myself
because i don't want to spend that much
money
like for a guy that you know navarro
exactly or specifically like for a guy
that wants to say
he's innocent he's unwilling to give
over the documents to talk about uh what
he did or rather talk about what he
didn't do if he's so innocent
and then say
i'm gonna take the cheap route here i'm
gonna i'm gonna represent myself but i'm
gonna ask you for money
to pay for a lawyer but i'm not actually
gonna pay for so it's very like trump
right like help me with this fund i need
to defend myself but i'm not actually
going to use the money for what i said i
was going to use it for
well here is here's a little bit of the
uh hearing and the coverage that we did
yesterday on the hearing again everyone
go follow on midas touch youtube channel
we'll be doing the hearings next week
now those links will be coming out soon
so make sure to set reminders for those
but here's some of the footage from
yesterday's hearing of our coverage of
john eastman plea
pleading the fifth just a few days later
dr eastman emailed rudy giuliani and
requested that he be included on a list
of potential recipients of a
presidential pardon because that's the
news that we got is that he was
pimping for a pardon here on an email
and then here is dr eastman pleading the
fifth so
did the trump legal team ask you to
prepare a memorandum regarding the vice
president's role in the accounting of
electoral votes to join session of
congress on january 6 2022.
dr eastman before they finish the
vice president could reject a lecture
from seven states
and declare that the president had been
realized
like he knows where the questions are
going right and he goes
that's gonna be a crime that's gonna be
a crime that's gonna be a crime because
that's the thing here is he's sweeting
fit to not self-incriminate himself yeah
is what he's doing he's crazy
the first sentence of the memo
starts off by saying seven states have
transmitted dual slate's electors to the
president of the senate is that
statement in this memo true
even his lawyer here look at look at him
holding up
shut the [ __ ] up stop talking why did
why did you say you were gonna show up
to this oh my god damn it now i'm [ __ ]
it it only it only gives us
more it
a hundred times
john eastman would have
self-incriminated it and that's how we
have to look at this at this point
because he was looking for a pardon
even after january 6th so john eastman
is our winner for bow net of the week
folks let's give him his due
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
john eastman born into the week what a
patriot i mean patriot i mean what a
loser
i plead the fifth okay so everybody if
you want to participate in bone end of
the week go follow us on twitter tony
michaels pod every single week there is
a poll there for bonen of the week also
subscribe to the youtube channel the
tony michaels podcast the poll will be
there as well you never know what's
gonna happen in our elections gabe
because we
we do not rig these elections no you
vote you decide we break it down for
bone end of the week stick around right
after the music we'll have some messages
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh gabe what a great bonehead of the
week i i like that they voted uh john
eastman and i think that was appropriate
i was scared that herschel walker was
gonna pull that out it was so close it
might look like you know based on how it
laid out in the video i gotta look at it
again but it was it was very close like
they were you know like i said they were
two percent different so bonehead neck
and neck though just know that john
eastman won
by hair by hair
gabe we're gonna do these hearings uh
next week there's two of them right now
they're slated for tuesday uh the gavel
goes down at one eastern but we will
start our coverage one hour early just
like we did every other the three prior
uh hearings so they'll start at noon
eastern over on the midas touch youtube
channel so go subscribe to the midas
touch youtube channel be looking for
those links also follow us on twitter at
tony michaels pod we'll be retweeting
those as we get those links for you to
set reminders don't forget to hit the
subscribe button here on the podcast on
youtube
every single weekday we bring you the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends the
hard hitting news here for commentary on
the tony michaels podcast monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific for two full hours on youtube
twitter twitch and simulcasting from the
midas touch facebook page
also download every single episode
on youtube or excuse me
spotify google
uh apple all your favorite directories
download and gabe you know we do a best
of the week so we're gonna have a best
of tomorrow right um for tomorrow we'll
have a best of the week that you can
download on the directories and then
bone end of the week the segment we just
got done doing we will cut it out and we
will also place that on the directories
so seven days a week you can download
those games seven
days a week and boy have we had some
great downloads boy have we had a
audience getting bigger and bigger and
bigger we appreciate it every single one
of you joining in
and commentating with us
as we go through the news and as we pick
apart these right-wingers to save our
democracy
every single weekday monday through
friday and until monday at noon eastern
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass